this is from the daily beast that says
the office actor rayne wilson who
obviously played dwight schrute came a
bit too close to embodying his
inflammatory tv character dwight schrute
on wednesday when he tweeted a poor
attempt at a joke about transgender
people
he tweeted quote t.i.l you can no longer
say nursing or breastfeeding mother you
have to say chest feeding person
just fyi that was the tweet
which i guess is supposed to be it's not
even a joke that's just a
that's just true that's like what the
left is trying to do they're trying to
to uh
supplant breastfeeding with chest
feeding
so he tweeted this and then uh but then
he tweeted an apology i think we have
the do we have the actual tweet from him
um he tweeted apology said yesterday i
tweeted a mean crack about breastfeeding
versus chest feeding after speaking with
some tren trans friends and educated
educating myself a bit more i want to
apologize for the tweet it was adding to
misinformation and meanness i'm sorry
so of course
he immediately came again what he
originally said was not even a joke or a
crack about trans people
he was pointing out
that chest feeding has become the new pc
term of art which is true
uh but then he had to apologize for that
because he was educated by his trans
friends
educated about what exactly what did
they what did they teach you is what i
want to know
and the thing about this whole
breastfeeding versus chest feeding thing
is that that it doesn't even make sense
okay even on even on the the left-wing
premise here it doesn't make sense
it's exactly like the latin x le tinx
thing
well we need to have le tinx because
it's gender neutral hispanic is already
gender neutral
you could say latin and that's gender
neutral
so along with all the other problems of
latinx the first problem is that it's
not by your own
premise it's not necessary
and it's the same thing here chest and
breast these are synonyms
essentially
like
men have breasts there's a reason why
men can get breast cancer it's rare but
men can actually get breast cancer it's
rare because they have less breast
tissue
but men have breasts
and the words are basically used
interchangeably
so this it's a distinction actually
without a difference in the first place
so when we're told by the left that uh
well we need to say chest feeding
instead of breastfeeding because it's
more inclusive that doesn't make any
sense
the two words are synonymous
now
what the left will say in response to
that is well if they're the same then
why can't you just change it
if it's if it means the same thing
anyway then why not just say chest
feeding instead of breastfeeding
no no that's not once again
i don't have to provide that explanation
to you
no it's more like why should we change
it
if it's basically a distinction without
a difference
and the change doesn't make any sense i
don't have to explain to you why we
shouldn't change it we've been using the
term breastfeeding forever everybody
knows what it is
you're the one suggesting the change you
have to explain it it's not up to me
you're proposing the change so that's
something that you have to defend
why is this necessary
but of course you can't defend it
the only defense is that well it makes
trans people feel better why does it
make them feel better number one
um
so we talk about breastfeeding that make
that makes them feel sad why
and then the second question is why
should i care that much in the first
place
why should we have to go through this
great effort to change a term that
everybody has been using forever and it
has caused no problems for anybody and
now we've got to change it because a
couple trans people have their feelings
here
explain that to me
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts